what's going on everybody and welcome to
a tutorial with Python and - if you
don't know what - is basically the idea
is it's both to help you with data
visualization but also embedding that in
some sort of web-based UI now of course
I said I guess I should really say
browser-based UI you don't actually have
to be connected to the web and because
of that I really do think that's
probably going to be the future so as
opposed to doing something that graphs
in like like with matplotlib and tkinter
there's really no reason like every
machine has a browser so so why we need
that to be a standalone application I
don't really think that's going to be
the case or needs to be the case so
anyways it's really browser-based and
the idea is that you know not only do
you need to create a graph oftentimes
but you also need to embed that graph
into some sort of user interface and
oftentimes that user interface is going
to be a completely different framework
from what you're using right now and you
know making the to interact together can
sometimes be quite the challenge and
take quite a bit of time and require a
lot of code so what - is aiming to do is
to help you not only make your graphs
but also make the UI surrounding that
graph much much easier so what - does is
it incorporates HTML with react
JavaScript and and then all obviously
the plotly graph so plotly is who's
behind - so I actually just kind of
stumbled on - I hadn't really heard much
about - until I was trying to I was
looking into something with bouquet and
then I saw people comparing - to bouquet
and people were just saying yeah - is
pretty cool
and so I just looked into - because I
hadn't I had even found like a PI
contact somebody that was covering like
all the visualization libraries and -
wasn't talked about I mean plotly was
talked about but I feel like it's a
little unfair not to mention - on that
because this is really cool so what I
have here
I've been revisiting a project of mine
putting a computer in a car you don't
really need to know anything about any
of this stuff it's just just look at it
for the UI sake but the idea here is
that we're graphing various things that
are being read by
sensor and what's cool about - and
really all this stuff is like is you
know you could start with this and first
of all yeah the graphs are live and yeah
we could hover the graphs but we can
also we can change things dynamically
and just it's just updated live for us
thanks to react and - for combining
those for us so for example if I remove
one of these charts the other one it
just gets boom updated and it fits to
screen actually in that case I'm using
some CSS that I pretty much wrote myself
but or not wrote myself but had to bring
in but again it was super simple but
actually even that CSS though I'm
actually writing that in Python which is
cool but anyways yeah we can go to even
down to one or if we want to we can
continue to add more graphs like for
example and we can grab that one if I
continued adding them obviously we'd run
out of space but I could scroll down and
see the one I just added so anyways
that's one one quick example of
something that you can make with - and
now let me show you one more example so
here's another application I have built
with - so little simpler but same kind
of idea so in this case what we can do
is we're going to input a symbol that
represents a graph or a stock ticker and
then it just automatically is going to
pull and graph that information for us
so as I keep changing it we get a
different ticker and so on and now we've
got Apple here but again the idea is
that just by typing into here and using
react but I don't know I've never coded
any react in my life this works and it's
it's just super cool super easy and I'm
really excited to have found this and I
hope you guys are going to enjoy it as
well and with that let's go ahead and
get into the series all right so to get
pip what you're gonna get a pip to get -
what you're gonna wanna do is pip
install it so first we're going to do a
pip install and we're just gonna grab
quite a few things here we're gonna get
- we're gonna get - - render - - HTML -
components and then you would also want
- core components so you're gonna get
all this all so let's get plotly
and just for the record just in case I
forget to mention this anytime later on
you know the UI aspect of dash is
actually pretty quick and easy to to
pick up what might be a little less easy
to pick up is all of the plotly stuff so
plotly as you you might know is a
maturing framework for doing javascript
based data visualizations and basically
anything you can do in plotly you can do
in - so if you want to do like custom
graphs and stuff like that I would
highly suggest you check out like you
know just Google what you're trying to
do and chances our price someone has
already done it and then embedding it
into - is pretty simple but I will show
an example of us doing that exact thing
just doing a simple plot ly graph versus
- and all that so anyways make sure you
get all this you will need to run as
admin or if you're on Linux you know use
a pseudo if you hit an issue on Windows
with not having the proper compiler or
whatever
check out the text-based version of this
tutorial I put some examples there as
far as what you can do to fix that I
think it was at least for me I hit it
with markup safe but you can either
remedy the compiler itself or you can
get the unofficial binary anyway that's
in the text-based version head to the
Python program at net either search for
- or check the link in the description
there's probably a link to this tutorial
in the description so once you have
everything you are ready to rhumble so
let's go ahead and import - we're going
to import - underscore core underscore
components and then we're also going to
import - underscore HTML components so
the core components are going to be
things like graphs and stuff like that
in HTML components are gonna be things
like tags like div tags that sort of
thing so to start in an application
we're just gonna say app equals - dot -
and I will - is built as a it's a flask
app so you can combine this with flask
either making your flask app starting
from - and then you could add
shoot you were URL paths I'm trying to
think the proper term here anyway you
can you could do that with the rappers
you know or you can actually embed a -
application within your flask
application again we might cover that
little way later on down the road but
because for the most part my use of - is
for standalone applications not really
to embed but I might cover it down the
road anyways but even if I don't this
has been covered there are is
documentation for doing it so just keep
that in mind so then we're gonna do is
specify app dot layout and this is gonna
be something you're always gonna have
this is gonna be the HTML of your entire
project so we're gonna have HTML dot div
so this just starts a div tag and then
let's just say - tutorials for now so
this is just is whatever goes within
that div tag so we're just gonna throw
in some text there and then now we're
gonna run the application so I'm gonna
say if our score I guess I should say if
dunder name equals dunder main we're
gonna do app dot run underscore server
and then we will set debug equals the
true even though it's never been useful
for me at least on my Windows machine
now I'm probably gonna have an issue
doing this still running that other let
me run this real quick let's just see if
this works but you should see up HTML
what do we do oh so - core components
will import that as DCC and then the
HTML components will import as HTML try
again cool so now I had that other app
running let's just see if I can refresh
I probably can't yeah so it's still so
this is something you're gonna hit it's
at least if you're on Windows I haven't
tried developing with this on Linux so I
don't know if it's is hard but it's
actually pretty hard to stop this server
from from running let me pause just for
one moment why bring up task manager so
as truly lame as this is once you have
started this server it does become quite
challenging to get it to stop so the
best way I have found is one whoops
one is too close all the running servers
and then what you're gonna want to do is
come over here and stop the running
Python task which is going to close what
you're working on and then make sure
you've got obviously your apps and then
you've got your background processes
you'll want to check the background
processes too because one's going to
sneak right in there now what you're
gonna want to do is come back over here
and then we'll just restart this one and
there we have - tutorials now I know
some people are going to be like oh
that's horrible
that is pretty annoying but I will say
the only time you're gonna have to deal
with that is when you start a new script
so so you'll see here this is running
with stat so what we're gonna do is what
we can say is like - tutorials you can't
even see it
hold on I'm off the screen I'm on the
screen we'll do it again
- tutorials this is this is a there we
go so as you can see right here it just
says - tutorials but when we save this
I'm restarting with stat as well
when we save this you'll see it says
restarting with stat and now we can
actually just refresh this page and
you'll see it's been changed so as long
as you're working within the same script
it's not gonna be a problem it's only
when you you go from running one server
because this basically runs a local
server on your machine so it's only from
when you go from running one server to
another server that you start to start
to have issues so so just keep that in
mind that if you are hit it that first
of all don't close this but if you are
hitting issues just just going to task
manager kill the task if you're on Linux
you can also just kill the task with
like top or H top or something like that
and there's also like task killer or
something like that I think test kills
actually windows anyway you can look it
up figure out it can't you know just
close all Python tasks although I'm not
sure you should do that on Linux
anyways I would do it probably via top
but anyways let's continue so we've got
- tutorial so this is a really spool app
layout now let's talk about the more
realistic way that you're probably going
about doing this so you've got HTML div
which contains everything now when you
just have some text that's going in the
HTML div that's one thing but chances
are you're gonna have IDs you're gonna
have styles you're gonna have classes
stuff like that so it's gonna get really
challenging to figure out what the heck
is which if you don't label this so the
the actual contents are going to be
referred to as children and children can
either be a single element like that or
we can actually make it a list so I'm
gonna make it a list so one of the
children will be - tutorials the other
thing that we can do is we can we can
apply a tag to the children so for
example we could say HTML dot h1 so this
will apply a header 1 tag 2 - tutorials
so again if we save this and we come
here refresh now you can see okay header
1 awesome fancy so now while it's fun to
do HTML stuff we really can't here for
the graphs so let's do a graph so this
is one of the children now let's add
another child and just like with HTML
you know you can write it sloppily or
you can try to style it and obviously
it's gonna be a little challenging to
style HTML from within Python but we'll
do our best so at the start of the list
I'm actually just gonna hit enter and
then I'm gonna hit enter for the end of
the list and then now to add each
additional element here I'm just going
to do a comma and then go so now let's
add a graph so graphs are gonna come
from the DCC so the - core components so
I'm gonna say DCC graph and really
that's all you would have to do to add a
graph you just throw in that component
now you need you price should add some
information to that graph so so let's do
that now so let's just say this graph
has an ID of example and then what we're
gonna say is we're going to give it some
information so we're gonna say the
figure itself and very quickly this is
what's becoming your typical plot lead
graph so within your figure you're gonna
have a data element let's just do this
so data and
your data oops is going to consist of
either a single dictionary or a list of
dictionaries so if you had just like a
single dictionary that would be like a
single line or a single set of bars but
what we're going to do is a list so
we're gonna have let's do some lines and
some bars so for our data what we're
gonna say is first we're gonna have you
know you're gonna have some X's and then
you're gonna have Y's and then we'll
have a type oops don't do that we'll try
to keep it all single quotes type will
make that a line and then we'll give it
a name as votes so now let's give it
some values here so let's say X is 1 2 3
4 & 5 and then Y can be I mean this can
really be anything anything you want now
what we're gonna do is it looks like I
came off the screen a little bit I'm
pretty sure you guys know it's so over
there but let me make this a little tiny
bit smaller just so you guys gonna for
sure see everything there we go okay so
there we have some data but let's add
one more bit of data and in fact let's
just keep with the styling here okay and
then let's make this a little different
I'm just gonna re-enter some some random
data here cool and then rather than a
line here let's make this a bar and then
rather than boats let's make this cars
so that's our data so then besides data
we can have other elements let's call
this one like layouts and then layout
for example we can add all kinds of
stuff for now let me just do we'll just
add a title title
and then we'll call this basic - example
okay
barring some sort of syntax error which
we'll find out in a second okay so we
didn't have any syntax error so that's
another example if you air out you'll
probably have to close all your Python
stuff when you could go to restart so
try not to write errors because it's
annoying
now we'll just refresh all right and now
we have a basic graph here made with -
now of course most of this is not really
UI based this is just it's mostly just a
graph that we've stuffed into our app
layout and really the graph is pretty
much a plotly graph that you might see
but nonetheless we've we've actually
done it we've made the graph and all
that so now what we want to do is
continue working on the actual user
interface aspect and the interact
ability the dash gives us with with
react and JavaScript and all that so
that's what we're gonna be doing in the
next tutorial is getting more into depth
with the actual UI aspect of things
because you know you really once you
once you've figured this out how to make
this graph honestly you can make pretty
much all the graphs in all of plotly so
so I really don't see much point in
spending too much time going over those
but getting through the actual - and
making of UI and stuff like that that's
where it's a little more complex but
anyways we will graph a few more
different types of graphs and get live
graphs and all that in the coming
tutorials that said if you have
questions comments concerns suggestions
whatever feel free to leave them below
if you didn't know we do have a discord
server now so if you want to come in
chat with us you've got questions that
you want to answer it in real time come
join us on the discord app I will put a
link in the description for the invite
there to our Channel otherwise I will
see you in the next tutorial